اذا مجموعه فيلق روسيا الحره تخطف المشهد
في الحرب الاوكرانيه بعدما نفذت احدى اكبر
عمليات التوغل المنطلقه من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه منذ بدء الحرب نحو روسيا في
هجوم النادر في منطقه بلغارد من هم هؤلاء
الجنود الذين يقفون وراء هذه العمليه فيلق
روسيا الحره ووصفهم الكريم بالارهابيين
ومن اين جاءوا المقاتلون مشاهديناهم اعضاء
في وحده متطوعين روس يقاتلون الى جانب
القوات الاوكرانيه ضد بلادهم وسبب النقمه
هي النقمه على سياسات الكرملين يعود تشكيل
هذه الحركه المنظمه الى مارس 2022 وفق ما
كشفته صحيفه نيويورك تايمز الامريكيه التي
قالت بان فيلق روسيا الحره يعمل تحت مظله
الفيلق الدولي الاوكراني وهي قوه قتاليه
تضم وحدات مكونه من متطوعين
وبريطانيين وايضا من جنسيات اخرى بالاضافه
الى بيلاروسيين وجورجين وغيرهم هذه القوات
مشاهدينا تشرف عليها القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه ويقودها ضباط اوكرانيون وفقا
طبعا لنيورك ولكن اغلب عناصر هذه القوات
من دون خبره عسكريه ومنهم لم يبلغ العشرين
عام يقول التقرير رغم نفيكياف لاكثر من
مره الصله المباشره بهذه المجموعه تختلف
اسباب تطوع هؤلاء الشباب في صفوف الجيش
الاوكراني ضد جيش بلادهم ما بين نقماتهم
على الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين
ومعارضتهم لقرار الهجوم الروسي وانهم
كانوا يسكنون بالاساس في اوكرانيا عند
بدايه الحرب وهم الان يدافعون عن هذه
البلاد التي تبنتهم
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات